Tributes are pouring in for Matthew Perry,
the actor best known for his role
as Chandler
Bing in the smash hit sitcom Friends.
Fans in New York
set up a makeshift memorial outside
the apartment made famous by the show
Saturday Night Live honored
Perry, who hosted that program
26 years ago during the height of Friends
singer Adele even passed her
show in Las Vegas to share a few words.
Listen
So my favorite memories
of when I was younger with my friends
and one of my friends answered
when I was like 12,
get the best Chandler impression.
And he with her
all the time to make us laugh.
And if any of us are having a bad day
or feeling those,
you just pretend to be Chandler.
And I remember that character
for the rest of my life and all of it.
You know, for the first time,
I heard your friends call
me because
I was so them with his struggles
with addiction and sobriety, which I think
is incredibly, incredibly brave.
And yeah, just how much I love
what he did to feel special
to what he did to me.
Now, the co-creators of Friends
are remembering
Perry, saying in a joint statement,
We are shocked and deeply, deeply saddened
by our beloved friend Matthew's passing
it still seems impossible.
All we can say is that we feel blessed
to have had him as part of our lives.
Perry was found dead in his Los Angeles
home on Saturday.
That's according to the Los Angeles Times,
which cited law enforcement sources.
Authorities say
there were no signs of foul play
in an investigation
into the cause of death is underway.
Matthew Perry was 54 years old.
Rebecca Sun is a senior editor
at The Hollywood Reporter,
and she joins me now from Las Vegas.
What a nice tribute from Adele
and she really voiced
what so many people,
strangers really loved about both
his character on friends
and the man himself.
What have you learned about the reaction
in the last 24 hours?
It's just been stunning.
I think that the reaction was,
as Matthew Perry said last year,
actually during his
book tour, that people might be shocked
but not surprised by news of his death,
which is really quite sad.
I think that he was so public
and open about his struggles
with addiction
that as soon as the news broke you know,
I think anybody who was somewhat familiar
with him, even his fans,
you kind of had a sinking feeling about
perhaps what might have been the cause
But, you know, he was so beloved.
I think that Chandler's certainly for me
as well as fans around
the world is truly like Adele said,
one of the great characters
in television history.
Absolutely.
And so many generations
can relate to that.
And so many people
all over the world, Friends was dubbed
into so many different languages.
I want to show you now,
you know, we've had a lot of reaction,
but one of them also from Canadian
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau,
who tweeted or I should say is said on X.
Matthew Perry's
passing is shocking and saddening.
We'll never forget the schoolyard games
we used to play.
And I know people around
the world are never going to forget
the joy he brought them.
Thanks for all the laughs, Matthew.
I mean, this is the kind of outpouring
that we've had
and many people may not have known here.
He had a fairly really normal
upbringing in Canada
before he returned to the United States
for his acting career.
Well, some people are wondering about,
though, I have to ask you, is
we haven't heard from the fellow
cast members yet.
Why not?
I think that
I imagine that as the people
who were among the closest to him,
certainly professionally,
they probably need to take some time,
you know, for themselves
to to process this.
You know, I know that their reaction
is what those of us
who kind of only know them
as the group of friends, you know,
they're
the ones we're waiting for the most,
but they need to emotionally process
this themselves.
They they had an intense, unique
one of a kind experience
that only the six of them
shared for an entire decade.
They might, you know, want to be talking
to one another and seeing if they want
to make some sort of group statement.
But but but I think that's what it is.
I think that it speaks to the magnitude
of this type of loss to them that,
you know,
they're not doing some sort of quick,
quick reaction on Instagram, not just yet.
Yeah.
As you said, the magnitude of the loss
that everyone is still dealing with.
If we deal with his acting career, though,
I mean, it has been said that,
you know, as shocking, perhaps the details
of his personal life was his performance
was comforting in his consistency
and its comedic timing on friends.
You always waited for that line
from Chandler Bing to see what
he would come up with.
Exactly.
I mean, I think that the show creators,
you know, have said before
that initially he was
his character was the hardest to cast.
They thought it was Chandler
just really badly written,
you know,
why is this guy so hard to cast in?
As soon as Matthew Perry walked in
for his audition and Matthew said
that he had sort of he was the one
who created that unique Chandler cadence.
Could I be any more funny?
You know, that I everybody around
the world knows that.
And that was what he brought
to the character.
And as a result, that that combination
of screenwriting dialog and performance
you know, created
the magic of Chandler and.
And yeah, it's it's
that's a legacy that will always live on.
Yeah.
And in terms of what we have to say, it
it is sad
he wrote it himself in his memoir.
But do you believe it in
so doing though, that definitely
he kind of gave resolution to everything
that happened throughout his career.
Right.
Because he got to write about it himself
in that memoir that that came out about a
year ago.
Yeah.
I mean, I think that and it's eerie
because it was almost exactly a year ago
that the memoir came out in the memoir,
you know, I think maybe people were
sort of expecting a typical celebrity
memoir out, most of it being showbiz
stories.
But really a lot of it, it's
about his lifelong battle with addiction.
And and he says somewhere and it's a quote
that's going viral on social media today
that he knows that his legacy people are
it's going to be friends, is going to be,
you know, the first, second
and third paragraph of his obituary.
But what he hoped his legacy would be
would be to give hope to anybody who's
struggling with addiction and substance
abuse through sort of opening up his life.
And so I am glad that he had the ability
to really complete that book
and to get out there and tell that story,
because I think that's
what he wants to be.
He wanted to be remembered it was so for.
It was certainly an act of courage
from someone who remember
really for their comedy.
And as you said,
it will be an indelible moment
for all of us when we remember
how he reached out to people and said,
I want to help people.
I want them to know they are not alone.
Rebecca, Sam, we have to leave it there.
Thanks so much. Appreciate it.